[Musique]
le gouvernement a déposé hier soir un
amendement au sénat pour instaurer le
vote par anticipation
c'est surréaliste anticonstitutionnel de
mon point de vue parce que de nature à
porter atteinte à la sincérité du
scrutin
la france c'est pas les états unis le
vote par anticipation se ferait dans
certains bureaux via une machine à voter
à une date qui sera fixée par décret
durant la semaine précédant le scrutin
trouvaille de dernière minute dont
personne ne parle et le vote par
anticipation qui s'intéresse dans ce
pays pourquoi
quelles sont les expériences auquel il
se réfère pour dire ah bah c'est mieux
par la force des choses c'est suspect
donc il n'en est pas question
quant à la manipulation elle est
flagrante puisque en première lecture à
l'assemblée le gouvernement n'a pas
présenté à la représentation nationale
cet amendement il le sort de je ne sais
où comme si le gouvernement voulait
passer sous le radar du contrôle
parlementaire du contrôle du conseil
d'état alors qu'il s'agit quand même de
l'élection du président de la république
c'est l'élection qui est la clé de voûte
de toutes nos institutions
comme si le gouvernement avait honte et
voulait dans la précipitation cacher des
choses qui pourraient être inavouables
il a montrée justement à quel point le
rassemblement national était faible
sur le fond c'est un géant de sable le
rassemblement national et marine le pen
c'est une géante de sable qui s'écroule
très rapidement parce qu'il n'ya pas de
fondations bien sûr qu'elle est méchante
bien sûr que c'est une ennemie de la
république bien sûr qu'il faut la
combattre à lui mais mais mais c'est lui
ouais bah est pas gentil me semble-t-il
pour ce que nous pensons être pour la
france l'argument moral ne suffit pas
c'est une petite phrase de la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur qui fit
polémique depuis dimanche
je pense que l'islam au gauchisme
gangrène la société dans son ensemble et
que l'université n'est pas imperméable
universités fait partie de la société
décidément ce gouvernement utilise
l'islamo gauchisme pour à toutes les
sauces alors des fois c'est pour
discriminer une population de là cette
fois ci c'est pour cacher un bilan
désastreux madame vidal dans
l'université dans la recherche publique
c'est n'importe quoi
j'aime avec madame vidal plutôt que de
chercher à dire ce qu'il est juste de
penser ou pas et bien se cantonne à son
rôle de ministre de la recherche
son rôle de ministre l'enseignement
supérieur et qu'elle fasse aujourd'hui
par exemple quelque chose de simple
c'est qu'elle dise aux étudiants quand
ils vont pouvoir étudier quand je vous
disais on est tous le gauchiste de
quelqu'un d'une part et d'autre part il
ya la manière dont une idéologie et bien
indigéniste existe à l'université est
une manière de financer davantage les
recherches militante sur ces domaines
que d'autres recherches laissent violent
tout à fait dans son dans son champ
compétences au seuil a été franchi hier
quand on peut faire une proposition
aussi absurdes et ridicules que celle
qu'a fait la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur qui prétend confie au cnrs une
mission générale de police politique sur
leurs collègues dans la recherche à
l'université
c'est du jamais vu nulle part au monde
on ne fait ça à part peut-être en iran
même vidal et courageuse et la raison
alors elle n'a pas demandé si j'ai bien
compris je ne suis pas mis enseignement
supérieur
une enquête pour pouvoir sanctionner a
demandé une étude sociologique pour
savoir quel était l'état de la recherche
français c'est la conférence des
présidents d'université et qu'est ce
qu'ils disent ces braves gens ils disent
l'amour gauchisme n'est pas un concept
c'est une pseudo notion dont on
chercherait en vain un commencement de
définition scientifique et qu'il
conviendrait de l'essai sinon aux
animateurs de ces news plus largement à
l'extrême droite qui l'a popularisé un
panache rosé de cendres qui s'élève dans
le ciel de la sicile en italie
entre fascination et frissons hier dans
la journée le volcan de l'etna est une
nouvelle fois entré en éruption
ces conditions extrêmes ont provoqué la
formation d'au moins 4 tornade dont une
s'est abattue en pleine nuit en caroline
du nord
prenant tout le monde par surprise le
bilan est lourd trois morts une dizaine
de blessés et une cinquantaine
d'habitations endommagées